because you know what they might not
share your opinion on feminism of your
false stats or read the cutouts from
Cosmo putting them together with
different fonts like a serial killer
setting a ransom note maybe their their
garage doesn't look like that there are
too busy creating actual treatments and
finding cures for cancer that will save
women's live now hope the breast cancer
research halt the Human Genome Project
because Charles n blow is wearing a
[ __ ] hat
the New York Times decided to in the
wake of the sex scandals write about
Charles M blow but that's it uh question
of the day before we get to it when
you've been reading about the eruption
of sexual harassment and sexual assault
coming out of Hollywood but you know
post weinstein has your instinct been
like that if Charles M blows to think of
it as a male privilege or a white
privilege issue like him with the New
York Times or or did you instead of
looking at this through the prism of
gender or sex we can't say engender
anymore or race did you look at it about
as an issue regarding human decency and
treatment of women all people what's
more productive the New York Times real
news Charles n blow approach or looking
at this as a moral absolute d threading
of basic moral fiber in society you let
me know this is the article from the New
York Times this was trending everywhere
Charles em blow very first paragraph he
says weinstein is a jumping-off point
okay and then go straight to it the
recent rash of high-profile accusations
of sexual harassment from Harvey
Weinstein starting to George HW Bush and
Mark Halperin okay wine steamed okay
Weinstein is a repeat sexual offender
yes George Bush grabbed a sushi in a
wheelchair okay took advantage it's like
the old guy stealing stuff in the store
you kind of expected a little bit yeah
the older guy with dementia ramen people
at Costco with a shopping cart laughing
his ass off like 20 i producing was
Weinstein side job exactly I dabble in
producing but I find myself an artist of
rape George W Bush Mark Halperin okay
this is important to see that the
political angle is going on there any he
uses us to set up the checking mail
privilege the whole column is about
checking male privilege and he's ended
up with false stats so right away his
first statistic one in five women are
raped know we've been to this it's
about one in 1900 okay the one in five
set has been debunked actual FBI
statistics is 52 points something
forcible rape spur 100,000 women it's
one in 1900 that's not gonna stay around
I mean so minutes blow writes about it
next time
one in five women sexually assaulted on
college campuses if there's one five
women raped you would think there's more
sexual assault like on cases you won't
think it's the same number but again cuz
no other stats mean anything the survey
used to support this claim is incredibly
broad the CDC survey that he's quoting
actually asked a question about sexual
contact while drunk high drugged or
passed out and able to consent it didn't
actually even refer to specific
instances of unwanted sexual contact
that's where the one in five number yeah
comes from so it's important to note
that this is New York Times the most at
CDC survey right sergej this is the
problem talked about with the left with
Bernie Sanders or with with health care
statistics or what people a poll is not
a fact a survey is not a verifiable but
it's just effective to somebody it's the
only fact that it provides you with is
that somebody has an opinion that's a
fact
does his opinion matter no but we just
gave you as a pinion that's a number now
now that's a number we gotta spend time
on it makes another claim ninety one
percent of rape victims are female yeah
unless you talk about men being raped in
the prison population then it's actually
a lot more a lot more forever more
forever forever and you think with it's
ironic because Charlson blow is also
talked about black lives matter quite a
bit and he talks about the over
incarceration rates of black male yeah
yes then referring to the rape stat he
shifts no it's all women you know that's
untrue and again he's using this to set
up the male privilege check it he's
asking us all to check it now read you
his final paragraph if you haven't had
an aneurysm by then ninety percent
another claim is of sexual assault
victims on college campus do not report
the assault this is completely untrue
okay thinking of a famous graphic it
went viral with his ninety percent of
RIT we've probably seen an occupy
Democrat resist fascism dot org gov give
now IndieGoGo even Washington Post
debunked this as I noted FBI and rain
both estimate the number of unreported
rapes is closer to 35 or 40 percent far
cry from ninety percent crack some would
say statistically significant
now why does this matter is because he's
using all of these facts to politicize
an issue that really we should all be
unified in hey Weinstein's a germ sexual
assault is that this is what really
bothers me with the left today is they
take issues on which everybody agrees
and they make it seem as though we
disagree over it politically and then
talk about ah the gridlock in Washington
oh the polarization you've taken an
issue rape which nobody likes
aside from rapists small percentage of
people and you've turned the American
populace against each other you're
making it seem like we disagree on rape
and you think gonna find common ground
on anchor babies piss off so he claims
furthermore 2015 Cosmopolitan magazine
[Laughter]
New York Times the most respected CNN
the most trusted name right between the
top ten fall hairdos and how to
stimulate your boyfriend's frenulum
he's quoting cosmos and by the way even
then unfortunately we had to do some
digging into the cosmos surface here's
the truth of the actual cosmos survey
one of the main sources of the New York
Times let's keep going back to the
article it categorized sexual harassment
so broadly to include hearing sexual
explicit conversation hearing sex or
even getting dating requests so New York
Times is important is is allowing this
so when we talk about for example boxing
independent bloggers have no incentive
to fact-check any of their the New York
Times is using as their source a survey
from Cosmo which considers someone
asking you on a date to be sexual
assault
thanks New York Times not screwed so
either this all the set up his coup de
Gras that men don't have to worry about
being sexually harassed so what does he
say he says I'm a man six foot to two
hundred pounds able-bodied and
physically fit really I met the
privilege never being never even
considering the idea of being sexually
harassed or assaulted this is one of my
male privileges and
I have to check it I just threw up a
little only that's not true anything he
took Weinstein then went to George W
Bush and Mark Halperin because it's
politically motivated when we include we
know statistically it's not true but
even look at the reason Hollywood sex
scandals Terry Crews was harassed by a
producer
Anthony rocked by Kevin Spacey and by
the way if ever you trusted news just
just yeah just look at them feigning
like did you Kevin Kevin trusted name in
news coming up Kevin Spacey is gay
you're seeing Fred Claus that's your
research papers enough even Kevin Sorbo
was directly sexually harassed by
Versace just supported roughly so Kevin
he sidesteps so quickly avoiding some of
the most prominent sexual harassment
cases and this is his final his final
claim in the article which is really
what bothers me when I see this trending
if you are not actively working Charles
and blow to dismantle it you are
supporting it talking about patriarchy
it is not sufficient to simply not be a
sexist if you are a man you must also
recognize that you benefit from the
system of sexism in ways in which you
may not even be aware every man must
become a feminist every man must work as
hard as every woman to elevate gender
equality and to eliminate gendered
violence and yes I understand how hard
this can be constant outrage is
exhausting even about your own
oppression I'm a black man in America I
am worn threadbare dealing with the
oppression that men who looked like me
endure from racially skewed mass
incarceration oh there it is to being
the targets of political violence I
understand that all oppressions are in
some way intersectional and connected to
all other violence that the empathetic
connections of a lie ship are
multi-directional and reciprocal you are
a dick sir he's writing for the New York
Times and watch everything we just said
all the stats that we just quoted and
included even though I would say they
probably hold more water than Cosmo
because I called Charles and blow a dick
which he is they'll say this is fakeness
yeah so you know it's so funny to me is
he says it's not enough this is what the
letter does right it's not enough for
you to even agree it's not enough for
you to say equality is bad it's not
enough for you to say that women should
be paid the same as men every single man
must become a feminist and make my
finger all
thing that is their thing you should all
take an interest in my thing it's like
someone walking in here right now like
all of you need to be interested in
paintball cuz I'm on a team let's walk
down the logic trail
what male Republicans who have
historically pushed for harder sentences
against sex offenders Florida Governor
Jeb Bush signed a contract like the
Jessica Lunsford Act contrast that with
feminist liberal governors Jerry Brown
who signed bills to soften the
punishment for sex offenders it's we've
been pretty consistent on this if you
look at this Republicans have been
pretty consistently against rape sexual
harassment question chivalry and what
about something to me that's so funny
I'll you it's not enough you need to
become a feminist you need to do this
for if you care well what if instead
instead of just feigning outrage over
fake oppressions like you do what
instead of Twitter outrage what if
people don't have time for it because
they're actually doing stuff like
Francis s Collins head of the Human
Genome Project
okay who's counted amongst the greatest
medical achievements of our time which
is completely preventing diseases and
it's providing treatment get ready to be
tricked he's a white male and a
bible-believing Christian apparently
doesn't take enough time out of his day
no to to read Charles and blow article
German researchers axel Ulrich Michael
Shepherd Dennis Slamon who had developed
Herceptin to breast cancer treatment
judged to be one of the greatest medical
advancements of the last decade that
specifically saved millions of women's
lives guess what all them white males
but it's not enough you know then we're
not sharing your opinion on feminism of
your false stats or read the cutouts
from Cosmo putting them together with
different fonts like a serial killer
sending a ransom note maybe they're
their garage doesn't look like that
there are too busy creating actual
treatments and finding cures for cancer
that will save women's lives no hope the
breast cancer research halt the Human
Genome Project because Charles n blow is
wearing a [ __ ] hat let's look to that
man as a shining beacon of what we need
to do if we are going to fix the problem
of inequality in this country
it's the Twitter outrage it's the women
women's March you still listen I
appreciate that some of you white male
some people cheer for polio fine good
stuff we need but put on where is your
big house
stop everything de Rais vest is being
used in the new planet of evil
hey did you like this video of course
you did
let's there's something wrong with you
in which case you can comment below
what's your problem with this video we
want to hear from you and we promise you
100% I give you my word as my bond will
answer every single negative comment for
those who are normal you can leave a
thumbs up and subscribe